sus cánticos afirman que están
dispuestos a dar su vida y su sangre los
palestinos de cisjordania se movilizaron
de forma masiva el martes el llamado a
la unidad en solidaridad con gaza
jerusalén llegó a locales de todas las
edades por primera vez hay un solo
pueblo palestino de norte a sur de gaza
cisjordania y en jerusalén viene el
resto de nuestra tierra somos uno desde
la segunda intifada hace 20 años rara
vez se han visto multitudes en estos
lugares
esta pronto escalo tomando a muchos
fuera por sorpresa escuchamos disparos
de pistola desde el otro lado fue
realmente inesperado y escuchamos
disparos del lado palestino parece algo
así y entonces las fuerzas israelíes
dispararon mucho gas lacrimógeno y
munición real américas white frank
la ira aumenta la paranoia se desborda
estos jóvenes creían haber capturado a
oficiales israelíes estos jóvenes están
convencidos de haber frustrado una
infiltración de agentes israelíes
encubiertos
los manifestantes locales les cuentan
que los eventos que tienen lugar en
estas colinas de cisjordania están
claramente conectados con los eventos de
gaza y jerusalén y dicen que no ven un
final inmediato a la violencia